well Victor it's a pleasure to be here
with you to talk about your book the
impossible state in North Korea past and
future and I found that it was a very
interestingly structured book because it
has a part memoir part history and part
I guess what I would call international
relations theorists sketchbook on North
Korea what what were you hoping to
accomplish by writing this book and what
kind of impact you hope it'll have yeah
well I'm glad you didn't say punditry
is one of the other topics um well I
think I mean he's got the reason that I
wanted to write this book you know when
I left the government in 2007 I really
had no desire to write a book about
North Korea I've been dealing with the
issue for three years involved in
negotiations seeing everything you know
really close up and I just didn't have a
desire to write it then but five years
later and given the situation that North
Korea was in it seemed like a good
opportunity to write a little bit about
my experiences there a bit about the
history and about the US policy really
to a more general audience because I
think this is a sort of issue where the
educated reader doesn't really know a
lot about North Korea its history I mean
they see headlines about missile tests
about irrational leaders and all these
sorts of things and I just thought it
would be good to write a book that
people could look to as sort of a
comprehensive assessment of you know the
history the family the economics the
politics the human rights situation the
nuclear problem that that they could
look to every time they had a question
about what was going on with North Korea
so it's it's not it's not a I wouldn't
call it Scout a scholarly book though it
does have footnotes it is really written
to a more general audience that might be
interested in trying to learn something
about this country on the far side of
the planet
the book also has a point of view and it
I think is informed by your experience
in the Bush administration how did you
decide to kind of infuse it with that
kind of point of view you know a set of
arguments really about North Korea's
future that you know it's a little bit
different from a straight history I
would say yeah what I think any history
has an opinion in it and I think in this
case particularly the parts about US
policy I mean certainly they were
informed by my own experiences dealing
with the North Koreans in the Bush
administration but I thought I also
tried to give it an objective assessment
in terms of the overall view that every
US administration going back to wrong
reagan has tried to deal with this
problem Ronald Reagan had his own
engagement initiative George HW Bush did
Bill Clinton did George W Bush and
Barack Obama all did and so while I
think there is there are some of my own
personal views about how I thought
President Bush handled the situation and
there probably things in there that
readers might disagree with but I think
there are also things in there that
readers would be surprised about in
terms of what President Bush sought in
terms of diplomacy with North Korea
which is not normally something that
they would associate with President
Bush's views on North Korea and so that
was a natural thing that where I could
add something on this that perhaps other
authors who've written on the topic
would not be able to and you don't
necessarily take an idiotic elective in
your evaluation of the other
administrations but do you do give a
kind of critical review of successes and
failures of other administration's in
dealing with the issue one of the I
guess the basic thesis of the book is
that North Korea is the impossible state
because no one in sight is empowered to
overthrow it and no one on the outside
cares enough to
the costs of changing on and I want to
ask you about both of those in
particular you know starting with no one
is empowered to overthrow it why do you
think that that has been the case in
North Korea I mean especially from a
comparative politics perspective this
really makes North Korea and how it why
are compared to what we saw with the
former Soviet Union
all right I I think that that
observation is is quite accurate I think
when we look at the Soviet Union when we
look at the regimes in the Arab Spring
all of which have had leaders in power
longer than the former recently deceased
North Korean leader they have all
collapsed and North Korea continues to
survive so that alone is evidence that
nobody within the system is empowered to
overthrow it but I think it's also just
because as you know well I mean the very
strict controls that exist in this in
this country it's a society in which the
to use the term strong state would be an
understatement this is about the
strongest state in terms of the control
that has on the society and on political
freedoms and even thought even the way
people think and so for that reason it's
very difficult to imagine that that
there could be a group within the
society that could speak out that could
challenge views at a party Congress
these sorts of things just don't happen
in North Korea so that's why it has
lasted for this long I think because in
spite of a lot of its problems economic
problems human rights problems food
problems it has lasted this long and
that is because no one within the system
is capable of changing it but there are
potential forces for change going on
inside North Korea I mean you talk about
Morgana's ation you know information
flows you know we're not it's maybe post
totalitarian but we're obviously not to
the place where there's an organized
opposition how long do you think it's
going to take for us to see the
evolution of
politics in North Korea to a point where
it's possible for dissent to be
expressed yeah it's a good question and
as political scientists we're supposed
to be able to determine when these sorts
of things happen when you sort of reach
a critical tipping point but I don't
think we can I mean I don't think I
don't think we can say with any degree
of accuracy what the tipping point into
in terms of when a society is ready to
act up and rather than simply be follow
the follow the rules of the current
political system in the case of North
Korea as you say in the book I talk a
lot about the the element that I think
is new in in this picture which is the
growing markets in the country really
starting from the famine of the 1990s in
which people basically had to sell
whatever they could find a cup or you
know a pen for food and that was the
start of a market in a system that never
really had markets before and that has
been going on now for 15 years so I
think what we can say is that there is
this element there that was not there in
the past that has created more of an
independence of mind by the people in
North Korea and not and not being solely
relying reliance on handouts from the
government but when exactly that's going
to reach a point where the system will
tip you know it's very hard to say
and how do you think the state is
adapting to some of those changes well I
mean part of the way they're adapting is
they're trying to crack down on
certainly on the unofficial markets that
have existed some of the official
markets there have been efforts at
reform what you might call reform in
North Korea some of the Economic
Cooperation projects with the affluent
South Korea but these have largely been
aimed at bringing hard currency and to
help the regime not so much to create
real market reform in the country and so
I think that what we're seeing now if we
do see efforts at economic engagement
with the outside world the North Korean
leadership is doing this because they
see card currency
not because they are seeking necessarily
to create a better life for their people
and what in in what ways do you think
pockets have protests you know could
emerge or do you think that it's going
to be a case where anything that happens
is just going to be stamped out you know
do you see any possibility for the
elites you know tolerating of certain
forms of dissent yeah well right now
it's hard to imagine that and you know
the question as to whether you can you
know at what point we will see either
toleration of dissent or the emergence
of dissent you know again as social
scientists we can't predict them but
what we can do is we can point to
certain preconditions that exist that
could lead to that and so I think
certainly the market mentality is is is
certainly one of these things but you
know it's very hard to say well at least
there's not a lot of evidence that this
regime is tolerant of any sort of
dissent there's not a lot of evidence
that they have tried to listen to the
what the content of what app or whatever
protests have taken place in North Korea
and of course it goes without saying
that this is a country that there's it's
very hard to get any information on what
is happening inside the country so when
we talk about the center protest we hear
anecdotes we hear stories of things that
might have happened in this military
unit or in that city but we really don't
we don't really don't know and it's such
a hermetically sealed country yet I
think when the day comes where when it
opens up or however it opens up if it
collapses falls like and you see
unification like the Germany's I think
will learn a lot about what sort of
political dissent existed within the
country but it's very hard to find that
and insight that today so do you see the
regime
as really rigid and therefore more like
hoody crack or do you think that it is
flexible in the sense that it has
muddled through now you know despite
incredible global changes in the
international environment you know how
should we evaluate the character of the
regime in order to have a sense of what
might come yeah
later on I think it is if you if you
pose that spectrum I think it is more on
the brittle end of the spectrum and a
regime that will crack rather than one
that has sort of been malleable and has
managed to muddle through I think the
reason it has been able to muddle
through is because the second factor
that we talked about at the outside of
the conversation it's it's muddled it's
managed to model through not because of
anything internal to the system but
because of what's happening outside of
North Korea and and that is this dynamic
where nobody really wants to put in the
effort to change it or to solve the
problem and and there is one country in
particular that wants to ensure that
there is no there are no big changes or
unstable occurrences within the country
yeah well and that's I guess the second
part of your observation about North
Korea has an impossible state is that
nobody cares enough to risk the cost of
changing it and and really that I think
is quite striking when we look at the
history especially of how human rights
concerns have motivated desires for
international intervention mm-hm
in many other parts of the world you
think about Rwanda a Kosovo
you know Bosnia and yet somehow North
Korea hasn't been subject to that same
international activism despite the fact
that you know arguably the human rights
conditions are just as bad certainly for
large portions of population you know
how is it that that this is the case
what makes North Korea immune to that
sort of focus you know
community well I think when we say
international community we have to be
clear what we mean and I think we mean
sort of the developed West and there are
certain issues that the developed West
has taken up in terms of human rights
yeah you mentioned some of them I mean
very clearly they have taken up these
causes there are others Sudan Tibet
others that have been taken up to a
great extent by by the international
community but North Korea has just not
been one of these issues I think I mean
for two reasons the first is through
very successful efforts by the North
Korean regime to ensure that this
remains a nameless and faceless policy
issue and not a personal story a
personification of a story that that the
average American if you will will
somehow be influenced by or take up a
cause for many of the North Koreans who
defect through the border with China are
sent back by the Chinese on buses with
the curtains drawn so that there is
nobody that could associate a name or a
face with this terrible human rights
situation in in North Korea you know
just exist for by example South Korea
during its military dictatorships had
had this person in the name of Kim
dae-jung
who eventually won the Nobel Peace Prize
later became president of South Korea
who became lionized as a voice as a face
for a democratic activism in South Korea
no so you have Kim dae-jung in South
Korea you have Lacroix Lhasa you have
you have these these these personalities
that can be identified with a problem
and the North Koreans have been very
good at not allowing that to happen
Chinese have been complicit in that I
think that's certainly one of the
reasons why it hasn't been taken up yeah
the other eye I think is that it just
hasn't captured the imagination of some
major personality in the West I know
this may say bit caddy
but practically I think it's true when
somebody like Richard Gere takes up
Tibet or Mia Farrow takes up Chinese
policies in Darfur this gives a
resonance to the issue that you don't
would not normally see and in the case
of North Korea we just really haven't
had that we haven't had an individual
that that does that now I think one of
the things that we're seeing more of and
and and their stories of this in in the
book as well as Americans are learning
more about the stories of some of these
defectors that are getting out of North
Korea there have been several books that
have been written recently about
defectors who have left managed to
escape from North Korea telling their
stories and that and I think that that
certainly helps but still compared to
other cases of human rights we just
don't see the same sort of same sort of
resonance with regard to the issue you
know another distinctive feature of
North Korea that could have an impact on
the human rights set of observations by
the international community is the fact
that North Korea has been you know on
this drive to become a nuclear weapons
state and you know I think that's
particularly interesting when we look at
Iraq
[Music]
you were in the Bush administration for
part of the time that this you know
issue was playing out and you know it
turns out that you know we decided to
attack Iraq and overthrow Saddam Hussein
he didn't have nuclear weapons
the North Koreans arguably had just as a
possible regime but we decided not to
pursue that course of action with North
Korea how do you see the difference
between the two you know it's it's a
tough question to answer
with her account without recounting the
whole history of why the Bush
administration went into rock you know
that was not my area of responsibility
so I'm not really capable of commenting
on that but I think in the in the case
of North Korea I mean there too
I think there are two issues I mean the
puzzle is why Iraq and not not-not-not
why Iraq instead of North Korea but if
if in Iraq then why not also in North
Korea you know I think I think there are
two answers the first is that you have
China right
China sits right on the border with
North Korea the last thing the United
States or China wants is some sort of
confrontation or conflagration on the
peninsula that would somehow cause the
two to butt heads as they did in 1953
and so I think anytime there is serious
thought given to some sort of military
action this is constantly at the at the
top of the not even top but even halfway
up the escalation letter this is
constantly a concern that every every US
president I think has had to think about
seriously so I think that certainly
certainly one of the reasons the China
factor and the other is that we United
States went into Iraq or went into
Afghanistan because it became the top
foreign policy issue on which the
administration sought a resolution a
final resolution now we can debate
whether that was the right or the wrong
thing you know many Americans think it
was the wrong thing many Americans think
that nothing was resolved there and you
know and that's a completely different
question I mean I think that the point
for Korea is that I don't really think
that the North Korea issue has risen to
that level of priority for an
administration it has been a crisis that
you wanted to sort of solve at least in
the sense of preventing it from becoming
a bigger crisis through diplomacy but
the United States historically when it
has sought to solve a problem it has
been willing to use both force and
diplomacy to really try to solve the
problem and I think in the case of North
Korea that that is just it is just not
registered like that and that is not
specific to any administration I mean
we've had crises with North Korea for
successive administrations and every
administration
has made the same calculation when we
reach a crisis with North Korea are we
willing to go all out to the end to
solve this thing or do we want a
solution that will at least Park it
momentarily put it on a diplomatic track
freeze it cap it and then move on to the
other issues that most concern us you
know whether it's the domestic economic
situation or Iraq or Afghanistan or
Syria or the Middle East peace process
these tend to be the more important
issues traditionally in u.s. foreign
policy yeah I mean the other issue that
makes it Rock different from North Korea
I guess is the us-korea Alliance and so
I mean how do you see the dynamics of
the Alliance playing into our ability to
address the top concerns that the US has
related to North Korea's nuclear program
yeah well I mean I think undeniably when
we look at the situation on the
peninsula the alliance with South Korea
is clearly more important than any
policy we have towards North Korea you
know South Korea is a is a key ally for
the United States today it is a major
partner and a lot of international
initiatives around the world big trading
partner all these sorts of things made
Korea South Korea extremely important to
the United States in terms of its
position in Asia and I think they're
always always been a tension in the
us-korea role in the u.s. South Korean
relationship when it comes to North
Korea because we have different
governments in a democracy in South
Korea some of which tend to be more
progressive would seek more engagement
with North Korea and others that tend to
be more conservative which follow are
willing to follow a tougher path with
regard to the north and so for the
United States you know it's a man it's a
question sort of syncing up with
whichever government is there at the
time as they deal with the latest North
Korean crisis so for example when I was
in government during the Bush
administration we had a progressive
government in South Korea that was
really quite engagement oriented with
North Korea and was willing to
countenance a good deal of bad North
Korean behavior in order to fulfill its
mission of
trying to seek long-term reconciliation
with with with the country in the north
and the Bush administration was not as
enamored with that particular strategy I
think currently you have an Obama
administration in a Lee myung-bak that
conservative government in South Korea
right now they tend to be quite very
much on the same page when it comes to
North Korea because both of them after
having been burned by North Korean
provocations really are of a mind to
kind of hold tight hold firm and require
that the north meet certain
preconditions before we have another
round of diplomacy so you know they're
they're you know a partner I've always
said that so 75 percent of our North
Korean policy is our South Korea policy
and in the sense that we need to say
stay synched up with our ally and with
Japan also our other major ally in Asia
whenever we're dealing with the North
Korea problem you know another aspect of
the book that you talk about is
President Bush's own personal interests
in the human rights situation in North
Korea and you mentioned I think the
aquarium's of Pyongyang is having been a
major influence on President Bush's
thinking and of course he had the author
of that book in the White House and had
other refugees in the White House the
parents of the Japanese abductee Megumi
Yokota mm-hmm and so he took you know a
kind of bully pulpit approach but
actually my impression was that the
human rights envoy that was a point it
really was not a major part of the
picture in terms of the policy right now
we have the Obama administration we
haven't seen any refugees in the Oval
Office but we have seen a human rights
envoy that actually went to North Korea
and you know talked with the North
Koreans raised human rights with the
North Koreans even though that was
probably a relatively short conversation
mm-hmm what do you see is the merits and
demerits
feature of those approaches well I think
I mean I think it's great that the Obama
administration's human rights on where
Robert King has been able to make a trip
to North Korea two trips or more two
trips to North Korea I mean I think
that's great I mean the more that we can
open a dialogue with these sorts on
these sorts of issues with the North the
better you know I think admittedly part
of what he was doing is you know well
was to try to negotiate a humanitarian
assistance package for North Korea in
terms of food more than it was to talk
about human rights abuses but the fact
that he was there I think I think was
very important you know Scott it's you
know while the dialogue with the North
Koreans on human rights is is it's kind
of a ridiculous dialogue because you can
tell them you need to improve your human
rights situation and their response to
you will be and we've had this
conversation at the official level the
response to you will be well you the
United States have human rights problems
too I mean a that is not a comparable
discussion and so I think what President
Bush wanted to do was he wanted to make
this an issue that people know about and
he wanted to as he put it he wanted to
do something he wanted his presidency by
the time he left the Oval Office he
wanted to do something that could help
to measurably improve the lives of North
Korean people and so I think there were
two things in particular that he did the
first was that he helped to create the
first defector resettlement program for
North Korean refugees in the United
States none had existed prior to this of
course there was a big program in South
Korea that exists and and that would be
to an extent expected but for another
country outside of South Korea and for a
country like the United States to say we
are going to take North Korean defectors
who want to settle in the United States
was a big step
the administration didn't try to toot
the horn publicly hey look at us we're
doing this big thing but it was a very
big and important step I think that sort
of the sort of set an example out there
and put a marker in the ground saying
the United States is not just talking
about human rights improvements in North
Korea it's trying to do something the
second thing as you mentioned was that
he he brought attention to the issue by
bringing in defectors people whose books
he's read stories he's known intimate
details that he's known very well about
all of these folks and talked to them
about the situation and then and then a
press statement saying that he met with
these people and wanted to see the human
rights situation improved with North
Korea I mean again giving names and
faces to this sort of problem helps to
give it a broader resonance and so in
the book I go through some of the
experiences of when these defectors came
into the oval office walking them into
the Oval Office watching them respond
watching President Bush responded really
were truly memorable memorable
experiences and so in the end I think
these things obviously did not solve the
Human Rights problem in North Korea
they're not opening up the prison camps
they're not allowing the UN Commissioner
for refugees into the country all these
sorts of things are not happening but
when you are limited in terms of what
you can do I mean everybody respects
sovereignty so you're not going to go
crashing into the country you know these
I think were very tangible and concrete
steps that tried to put this on the
radar screen and create more
international attention because that is
you know that creating that sort of
knowledge base and that sort of advocacy
environment is the first step to try to
address a problem like this now the book
also I guess goes through and
illustrates some of the the wrong
decisions that North Korea made in terms
of trying to build its own economy and
this is quite striking because as
you note in the book North Korea was the
more powerful economic part of the
peninsula compared to South Korea for a
long time until the 70s mm-hmm and then
you also talk a little bit about North
Korea's illicit activities and this was
also an area of focus during the Bush
administration that we don't really hear
that much about these days
and so I'm wondering do you think that
these activities are continuing are we
succeeding in squeezing North Korea in
terms of customers for some of its
military equipment and missile sales you
know do we see still activity by North
Korea in terms of trying to counterfeit
cigarettes or counterfeit US money or
sell drugs abroad where do you think
that stands at this point well I mean
this is a fad you know this is sort of a
fascinating story I mean the the notion
that here is a country that basically
one third of its economy is based on
illicit activities as you mentioned
counterfeiting drugs counterfeiting
cigarettes counterfeiting the u.s.
currency I mean the the North Koreans
counterfeit the u.s. $100 bill it is
known in in the profession if you will
as a super note because the North
Koreans managed somehow to acquire the
printing press the ink and the paper
that is used for the production of $100
bills the difference is that the
printing plates that they managed to
acquire are brand-new whereas the ones
the US Treasury uses are fairly old and
so the imperfections that you see in a
Treasury note you don't see in a North
Korean note I mean that's why it's
called the Supra no and so this these
are this is a part of their economy and
so during the Bush administration
efforts were taken to try to stop this
through a series of sanctions that were
aimed at trying to target the accounts
of
of companies that were known to be
involved in illicit activities and I
think the reason we don't hear more
about it today is because these
activities have been fairly successful
and that the North Koreans probably do
not feel that they can do the same sorts
of things that they used to do for many
years when it came to making money
through this sort of activity okay so
it's actually that the international
community and the US are getting better
at eliminating those markets for North
Korea for those kinds of activities I
think so
I think so I mean I think that's why
we're not hearing much more about it
today
but I also think that for many of the
financial institutions they've just
become much more wary of handling North
Korean accounts and North Korean money
and and so that has also caused the
North Koreans themselves to think about
whether they want to to be seen as being
this financially liable asset that every
bank regulator or bank president doesn't
want to see in their institution and one
of the other cases that's related to
that that you had direct experience with
was the Banco Delta Asia situation where
the US Treasury
you know issued an advisory about that
bank and the possibility they're always
engaging in money laundering or handling
some of these counterfeit notes how do
you see the and and of course that
occurred at a point in time when it
looked like there was going to be some
progress in negotiations and then it
seemed like everything stalled out how
do you see
do you think that that was the case with
BDA that it stalled the diplomacy and
you know as we look today at you know
more satellite launches possibly a third
nuclear test by North Korea you know it
seems like a lot of people are calling
for your re-examination of the financial
area you know is VD a replicable so
basically you know did it work from your
perspective and is it replicable today
yeah well the first thing I would point
out is the irony in the description that
you just gave which is that on the one
hand when when the the US government
pursued this financial sanction in 2005
2006 it was widely criticized as
something that was both ineffective and
hurting the diplomacy and yet today as
you said there are people that are
clamoring for it as a way to sanction
North Korea because they see it as a
powerful tool in terms of trying to
influence North Korean behavior so but
in 2005 this this particular action was
as you said it was a Treasury Department
advisory to US financial institutions to
be aware of doing business with a
particular bank in Macau Banco Delta
Asia because accounts in it related to
North Korea were and believed to be
involved in money laundering this in the
end was a law enforcement action it was
something I think the US government had
to do if a country is counterfeiting
your currency that is technically an act
of war and so they were obligated to
take action with regard to protection of
US financial institutions now as many
people who follow this know the effect
of that was it it had a ripple effect
this was and actually against a very
small bank in China that then caused
every other bank regulator and Bank
president and financial institution
around the world to say wait a second if
there if the u.s. is not
with this Bank because they're concerned
about North Korean accounts maybe we
should look at the North Korean accounts
in our bank and so you had this may
major ripple effect that had a real
impact on North Korea I think it had a
very big impact on North Korean now was
this meant as an action to submarine the
diplomacy that was taking place
I really don't think so like I said it
was a law enforcement action it was
something that was happening on a
parallel track with the diplomacy all of
us who are participating in the
diplomacy were also participating in the
in the in the decision-making process on
this particular action so it was and in
the end it was something that had to be
done and it did it did cause a delay in
in the negotiations but as we as we saw
later the negotiations eventually came
back online and it led to two very
important agreements one of which reef
froze the North Korean nuclear program
and a second agreement which actually
led to the dismantlement of important
pieces of the nuclear program at
jung-hyun such that it's pretty safe to
say today that the plutonium program
that plutonium based nuclear program at
Yongbyon is no longer functional and and
I think that was one of the
accomplishments that the United States
made in terms of diplomacy when it came
to stopping North Korea's nuclear
program now we have a whole new as you
know a whole new program or programs
that there is concern about not not just
the plutonium program but the Iranian
program but in terms of you know the
accomplishments that were made through
these new sanctions at the time these
new sanctions I think were quite
effective at getting North Korea to give
up at least pieces of their program yes
so do you think that there replicable is
an instrument today or is that time
passed um you know it's a hard question
to answer I mean again I'm not it's claw
be not as close to it as a as a as they
have been in the past so I don't know I
don't
for example if the North Koreans have
adjusted I presume they have to what
they saw in this in the action in BDA in
2005 I I think on the one hand the North
Koreans are probably adjusting and
trying to find workarounds so that
they're not subject to the same sorts of
sanctions on the other hand when the
United States pursued this I mean it was
an advisory to US financial institutions
it wasn't something that was supported
by the UN supported by UN Security
Council resolution on the other hand
today you know after the first nuclear
test against the Obama administration in
May 2009
you now have Security Council
resolutions that give authority for
pursuing these sorts of financial
sanctions so I think on the one hand the
North Koreans have probably tried hard
to find workarounds so that they could
have they could avoid being subject to
the same sorts of sanctions on the other
hand the United States now has the
international authority to pursue these
things in a way that they did not under
the Bush administration yeah one other
question on this you talked about you
know the resumption of the diplomacy but
of course as part of that we gave back
the money that was being held under the
law enforcement action that had occurred
I'm sure the North Koreans probably
looked at that as exoneration for what
they had done how do you view the fact
that the North Koreans got their money
back I think the main lesson that they
learned and again I think it's evident
in the fact that that we we don't hear
much about these sorts of activities
that they that they were undertaking the
main that lesson they learned from that
whole episode was they can't continue to
do business this way they can't continue
to try to counterfeit other countries
currencies or to sell fake drugs or fake
cigarettes they just can't do that
anymore
and so I think that was the main lesson
that they learned and the fact that they
came back to the diplomacy and back to
negotiations in earnest to freeze their
programs and to dismantle them to me was
a function of was a function of this
sort of course of diplomacy I mean I
think it was the concern about their
financial reputation and everything that
came with that that brought them back to
the table and that led them to make
these agreements now they certainly got
things in return I mean they got heavy
fuel oil they got energy assistance they
got new sets of political discussions
with the United States a variety of a
variety of eise or the assistance from
South Korea they got they got things in
return for this but of course that's the
nature of diplomacy but I think the
driving force behind that and I know
that there were some who would disagree
with this a driving force behind that
what were these sanctions that really
put a bite on them and of course they
still you know are driving for a nuclear
status even despite the apparent
agreements that had been made that were
designed actually to deal with the
plutonium part of the North Korean
program but let me go back and ask about
you know North Korean prospects for
reform they're still cash hungry maybe
we don't see any immediate evidence that
the leadership is committed to reform
but of course the Chinese are always
there suggesting that the North Koreans
should follow their path you know what
really is the way to cultivate an
environment where North Korea can move
you know in a reform direction you know
at this point it's still obvious that
they're looking for cash but you know is
there a a way of drawing them into a
positive path rather than pursuing the
negative activities that we've been
talking about well I think the positive
path that has
been on the table really I think four
successive administration's and and I
know there's always discussions about
the extent to which the Clinton
administration was different from the
Bush administration different from the
Obama administration in terms of how
they dealt with North Korea but in the
book I go through the history of eve's
and in the end they you know the
packaging may have been different but
there is a positive path that has been
on offer as you know well which is the
in return for giving up their nuclear
programs the United States the
international community would provide
security guarantees would provide
economic assistance it would provide
energy assistance it would provide
political normalization it would provide
money it would provide a regional
security environment in which North
Korea could feel safe and secure all
these sorts of things in return for
giving up their nuclear weapons but that
has that has not worked it has failed it
has failed for every administration
going back to George HW Bush and I think
with the Obama administration we have
really reached the end of the road in
terms of this because I think many would
argue that the Obama administration at
least in terms of its initial intentions
was probably the most forward leaning US
administration to come into office when
he came to the North Korea problem and
yet it is now in a position
indistinguishable from the hard harder
line that the Bush administration took
and even that the Clinton administration
took at times during their two terms so
the posit that is the positive path and
they don't seem to want to take it what
can be done in the interim I think the
most important thing that can be done is
to try to get more information into
North Korea more information in terms of
what is going on in the outside world in
terms of marketization in terms of the
Internet in terms of cell phones I think
this is this is the only way to really
make inroads into seeing any change
in in the country but from the
perspective of the leadership you know
economic reform is a double-edged sword
because on the one hand they need
economic forum as he said they need
money they need food they need these
sorts of things
on the other hand you know when regimes
like this open up it releases all sorts
of political forces that inevitably lead
to a loss of political control and even
possibly the collapse of the regime and
that's not a bargain that you know the
leadership particularly this new
leadership that is inexperienced and has
just come into power and that prize is
political control that's the last thing
that they really want to consider at
this at this moment so I'm not very
optimistic on the prospects for reform
at this at this time okay but the way
you framed it is very much a u.s. way of
framing basically a deal by which the
nuclear issue is resolved in exchange
for a reform path you know the Chinese I
think may have a different idea about
what would be necessary that is not
about quid pro quos perhaps it's about
the question of essentially the you
follow us and you can find a sustainable
path mm-hmm I think that's basically the
argument the question I have is based on
what we've seen in China
I mean North Korea hasn't necessarily
even seemed to be willing to dip its toe
in the water but you know what would a
North Korean dong shopping look like how
would we know if we you know began to
see a North Korean leadership that was
moving in the in that direction and you
know could a North Korean done shopping
succeed yeah well you know Scott I mean
you know I have many friends who are
Chinese scholars and when I talked to
those friends they are always optimistic
about North Korea the prospects for
North Korea and and I never understood
why and you know when you ask them they
say it's very clear why they're
optimistic because they have studied
China and they have seen China come from
where it came and the
for evolution in the great belief oh
great leap forward to be the country it
is today and they think if a big country
like China is complex and as complicated
as it is can do that then certainly
North Korea can do that but you know
again I think there there are two big
differences here the first is that China
had dong shell ping and as you said yeah
I mean dong Xiao ping was a carom at
charismatic leader a larger-than-life
figure
there is no dong shell ping in North
Korea there is an inexperienced 29 year
old who is running the country now he is
no dong zhuo paint so that's the first
problem the second problem is you know
the Chinese said to get rich is glorious
and making money was okay even if it
meant giving up a degree of political
control and for the current North Korean
leadership and at least for the
foreseeable future there is nothing more
important right now than political
control and that is that that looks to
be the case for the last leadership and
it looks to be the case for the current
leadership I think there are hopes that
this young fellow the Kim jong-un the
new leader of North Korea who spent a
part of his life in Switzerland in
secondary school that some that he the
people are hopeful that he might be dong
shopping but again given the the recent
crisis and the missile test and the
failed deal that the Obama
administration tried to reach with North
Korea I don't think there's a lot of
hope right now that he shows signs of
being a future a future dong shopping
maybe there is a military general
somewhere in North Korea that is unhappy
with the current situation that is
unhappy with a young leadership that is
making bad decisions that has a
different view on things you know maybe
there is a park jeong-hee a South Korean
park jeong-hee in North Korea but we
don't know and so right now the the
prospects don't look very good for that
sort of that sort of a forum or that
sort of charismatic leadership you know
some people would point to
Kim jong-un's uncle Chung Hong tech as
one possible reformer certainly he said
some international experience it's hard
to judge necessarily you know whether
he'd move in the direction of reform but
you know let's say that somebody you
know maybe junk some tech or someone
else emerged to play a park chung-hee
like role but within the same system how
do you think that the US government
would be able to respond to that
circumstance well I think they'd
certainly welcome somebody like that but
you know the the obvious problem I mean
first I think the US government would
certainly welcome someone like that
someone like a senior figure who was
interested in reform and interested in
taking North Korea to a better place you
know if there were if there were someone
like the generals we see in Burma today
in North Korea there that are looking to
make a big turn in terms of their own
system in the way they deal the world I
think the indices do welcome that but
the 800-pound gorilla in the room even
if that were the scenario still remains
the nuclear issue and this is where I
think when it comes down to its core
where the Chinese in the u.s. really
differ because for the Chinese I think
they certainly want want reform or ought
to promote reform as you see as you say
but they're also willing to say in order
to try to promote reform we should do
things like give them a peace treaty
ending the Korean War and normalize
relations with the United States and
DPRK as as as pre steps if you will to
to trying to promote reform I think the
problem for the United States is that
that's just not possible and every
administration going back to George HW
Bush has made pretty clear that the
number-one priority is the nuclear
program and the United States welcomes
reform absolutely in North Korea but it
must come with the nuclearization we
have alliances in the region or
in Asia rests on these alliances and I
don't think any of our allies Japan
South Korea let along the United States
would be able to countenance normalizing
relations having full political
relations with a country that remains a
nuclear weapons state completely outside
of the NPT regime it would basically
destroy the non-proliferation treaty
regime and would have a dramatic effect
on our alliances in the region so you
know this is the Rubik's Cube that is
very difficult to match up and has been
you know the basic problem every time we
talk about a big deal
getting a big deal with North Korea yeah
let me go back and ask you about that
because in the book you spend a lot of
time talking about you know issues
related to deterrence denuclearization
and you know a lot of people thought
that if North Korea conducted a nuclear
test that that would constitute a
paradigm shift in the region of course
you were there when North Korea
conducted its first nuclear test was
there something about China's reaction
in particular that surprised you how do
you you know how did you see the
response to that playing out and and how
did the response that you were involved
with you know in the Bush administration
you know what
what should we draw from that for
instance in the context of a possible
additional nuclear test by North Korea
in the coming weeks or months in the
short term it was a game changer in the
sense that we knew we moved to a new
level of international unity in terms of
punishing the North for these sorts of
actions in the sense that we had UN
Security Council resolutions really for
the first time in which China and Russia
were to sign onto these and unanimously
condemn North Korea and sanction North
Korea for their actions so in the short
term I think you that was a game changer
and since then every time the North
Koreans have done something egregious
for the most part the Chinese and the
Russians
and certainly gone long I said certainly
when it comes to nuclear tests but in
the longer term in retrospect that was
about the only real change it didn't
create this sort of game changing
mentality in the way the Chinese dealt
with North Korea you know there I think
there was a lot of debate in North in
China as to whether they should simply
drop this ally dropped this this legacy
of the Cold War and really helped to end
this regime that clearly does not happen
if anything the Chinese have drawn
closer to North Korea over the past few
years both economically and in terms of
politically supporting the new
leadership so in the end it didn't
create the sort of major change that
people thought it would and they get
part of it I think is the fact that the
status quo bias if you will in terms of
dealing with the North Korean and the
crisis is to try to just bring it back
down to try to lower the temperature it
is not to try to solve the problem and
and that is a political choice I think
that administration's in Washington and
Seoul in Tokyo and Beijing into Moscow
these are choices that they make because
in the end at least for now stability
equates to peace and prosperity in Asia
status quo equates to peace and
prosperity in East Asia you know the
most economically vibrant region of the
world and do people want that or do they
want to go down this very violent path
with North Korea potentially very
violent path with North Korea where you
try to solve the problem it's very clear
what every government wants to do they
want to maintain the status quo
well and that really brings us to the
question of Korean unification where it
seems that there's a big gap between the
u.s. vision and a Chinese vision and
also it involves what South Koreans want
in the future my impression was that you
were pretty bullish about the prospects
for achieving unification you also dealt
and to some degree with some of the
challenge
that would emerge you know at this point
you know how likely do you think it is
that Korea will actually be able to
achieve unification and and and how do
you see that process playing out in
terms of you know basically in a context
where China's influence continues to
rise yeah well I think you're I mean
your question is right I mean I don't
think the United States and South Korea
on the one hand and China on the other
hand have the same view of unification
the United States has said explicitly in
the joint statements of the past two
presidents with their South Korean
counterparts that the u.s. aspiration is
for a Korea free and at peace a single
Korea free and at peace that is the
natural order of things in the
international relations of this part of
the world a unified Korean Peninsula and
the Chinese don't the Chinese don't want
to see unification
they just don't and I think that's
become clearer and clearer in the past
couple of a couple of years I think
there really is a conflict of interest
between the two sides when it comes to
that in terms of the future and
unification it's impossible to say how
it would happen just like no one could
predict how are the conditions under
which German unification would happen
but I think what we can't focus on is
the question of whether countries in the
region are ready and willing to take on
the task of unification and I think ten
years ago that was not the case ten
years ago I think the general consensus
was unification is too difficult much
harder than the two Germany's too
dangerous and should be something that
should be pushed off for as far as you
can into the future to three generations
if you will basically not not my problem
no one wanted it to be their problem and
as I talked about in the book I think
the attitude on that is slowly changing
now in part because the the weapons
situation with North Korea is getting
worse and worse the human rights
situation is getting more
and worse and I think while no one wants
to try to push North Korea over the edge
there is a growing feeling that it is
coming and that we must be prepared and
I think you're seeing that sort of
change of attitude in South Korea I
think you're even seeing in places like
Japan where where the North Korean
threat is the biggest existential threat
to Japan today and while on the one hand
Japanese are always concerned about
reunified resurgent nationalism in a in
in in one Korea they see the current
situation as being quite dangerous
potentially very unstable and I think
their attitudes are changing on this too
so I think that in the book so I you
know we look and talk about sort of
those are the things we need to watch
because no one can predict unification
no one can say exactly when it's going
to happen but you know the question is
are you prepared for it and and that's
the operative question I think for the
societies and the governments in the
region and whereas before no one wanted
to think I talked about it at all I
think there's a much more openness and
willingness to talk about this now
I also want to ask you just to close
after Kim jong-il died you wrote a piece
in The New York Times you basically said
North Korea as we know it is over so far
we see a fair amount of continuity I
guess the question is you know how
durable is the impossible state yeah
well you know it all depends on how you
define North Korea I think North Korea
as we know know it with the death of Kim
Jong Il is over in the sense that as I
talked about in the book I think we're
entering a new phase where you have a
young untested leadership with immense
challenges in terms of maintaining his
own position in the system that is also
dealing with a crumbling economy and in
an in an acute food problem
and at the same time the society is
increasingly influenced by a market
mentality like is it like it was not the
last time you in 1994 when the first
leader died and the second leader came
came into place so in that sense the
North Korean today is not like the North
Korea in the past and sure it has not it
has not collapsed or it has not changed
since the death of Kim jong-il but you
know we're only talking a few months I
mean this new regime in North Korea has
only been in power for a few months and
in the broader scope of history there
have been many transitional regimes that
have lasted months years before
something major has happened in terms of
change so I think the the verdict is
still out on this I don't think that we
can simply assume that everything will
go smoothly and that they will be able
to muddle through forever because prior
to the death of Kim Jong Il in December
of 2011 if you had asked any expert I
would say including you Scott what would
be the most important variable that
could create major change in this
country
I think everyone would have agreed the
sudden death of the North Korean leader
so I think we have to respect what we
thought before and I think we all have
to watch very carefully what is going to
happen because I think the future of
this regime is not at all certain and
and the ramifications if something
happened will be huge for the United
States and for others in the region in a
way that will matter for the average
American and and and that's why I wanted
to write this book
well thanks Viktor I think that we had a
very good conversation and appreciate
the chance to further explore some of
the issues that are in the book thanks
very much Scott